we have four thousand five hundred
equals three thousands plus how many
hundreds question mark hundreds so let's
write this left hand side but I'm going
to write it out in terms of thousands
and hundreds so I'll write the thousands
in orange so this is equal to this is
equal to four thousands which is the
same thing as just four thousand plus
five hundred which you could also view
as five hundreds plus five hundred so
this is the left hand side now let's
look at the right hand side we have
three thousands so it's three three
thousands now let's not even look at
this right now let's just think about
what do we have to add to this right
hand side in order to get the same thing
that we have on the left hand side well
if you compare the three thousand and
the four thousand you see you have an
extra thousand over here so let's add an
extra thousand on the right so we're
going to add one extra thousand and now
we just have three thousand plus one
thousand this is make this makes it the
four thousand but then of course we also
need another five hundred so we're going
to need plus a five hundred right over
here so in order for these two things to
be equal we to say four thousand four
thousand plus 500 plus five hundred is
equal to is equal to 3000 3000 plus one
thousand five hundred plus one thousand
five hundred now the way they've set
this up we need to Express
so it almost looks the same on the left
hand side this is forty five hundred so
this right over here this is the same
thing as four thousand five hundred this
is this right over here and on the right
hand side we have three thousands so
that's this right over here
that's the three thousands and then we
just need to express this as hundreds so
1500 this is the same thing as fifteen
hundreds so let's rewrite everything we
can rewrite this as saying four thousand
five hundred just to get the exact same
form that they wrote it over there so we
could write four thousand five hundred
is equal to three thousands three
thousands plus now we have to just write
this in terms of hundreds well the
is 1500s literally if you took 15 times
100 it's going to be equal to 1500 so
this could be viewed as 1500s so plus 15
hundreds 100 so in this situation the
question mark is equal to 15